the film opens with Dana Kelly trying to
extract toothpaste from an empty tube
when squeezing the tube doesn't work he
resorts to cutting the tube open and
scraping out whatever remains with a
pocket knife despite his apparent
concern for Hygiene he reuses a piece of
dental floss hinting at his Frugal
lifestyle suddenly the Tranquil early
morning atmosphere is Shattered by the
beeping of his toaster rushing to the
kitchen he discovers his toast
completely charred later he proceeds to
eat the burnt toast while driving to
replace his old toaster Dana a penny
pinching resident of Austin searches the
stor room of the St Mary's donation
center for a used toaster s the center's
manager confronts Dana about his habit
of snatching items before they can be
displayed in the showroom Dana attempts
to persuade s into selling him the
toaster before any potential customers
lay eyes on it however s remains adamant
and instructs Dana to leave their
argument is interrupted by a customer
seeking a receipt for her purchase
meanwhile Dana manages to find a used
toaster he Bargains with sell
negotiating the price down from $7 to $5
and S reluctantly accepts the deal as
Dana returns to his car with his newly
acquired secondhand toaster someone
calls out his name the person introduces
himself as Bo silver a former classmate
from Dana's freshman year biology class
Bo jokingly admits to having cheated off
Dana during exams while Bo appears
well-dressed in a crisp shirt Dana's
appearance is more disheveled wearing an
old faded t-shirt Bo asks about Dana's
trip to Austin and the scene changes to
a flashback Dana is getting divorced
from his wife they are in an office with
their lawyers his wife's lawyer asks
Dana to sign the divorce papers and give
her half of his belongings he says
fighting the divorce in California is
pointless because the laws are more
favorable to women his wife also wants
the house the mercedesbenz and their two
chihuahua in response Dana's lawyer
reveals that his wife spent $100,000 on
credit cards in the first month of their
marriage Dana can't afford alamon
because he's still paying off his
medical school loans as as a result he
has to sell the house and the Mercedes
Benz Dana's lawyer then threatens to
make the divorce a and expensive legal
battle if he doesn't agree to their
demands exhausted Dana signs the papers
as the flashback ends Dana lies to Bo
and says he just wanted to leave La
after some small talk Bo invites him to
a poker game at his house that night
Dana reluctantly agrees at the poker
game Dana meets Hunter Bo's friend they
play poker for fun without using real
money Hunter is surprised by Dana's
Cheapskate nature and as he even
Bargains for a slice of pizza that Bo
bought for them the next morning they go
for a run around town Lake Hunter runs
ahead while Bo and Dana struggle to keep
up as a result Hunter teases them for
being old meanwhile two beautiful women
come jogging from the other side and
Hunter immediately starts flirting with
them as Hunter runs away with the women
the two friends start talking about
women Bo and Dana are both divorced and
Bo tells Dana that he should try casual
relationships he says it's easier for
Dana to get women because he's a doctor
Austin is full of beautiful women and
they can both start dating casually
later that evening Dana is at his
apartment reading a book on poker when
he gets a call from bo bo convinces Dana
to go to the club with him that night
since Dana doesn't drink he drives the
two of them downtown Bo reveals that
they are going to the famous dirty 6
Club where all the college students hang
out when they reach the club Dana
refuses to pay for parking and drive
several blocks down to save a few
dollars inside the club they meet Hunter
who makes fun of their fashion sense
after bragging about his genetics he
goes off to dance with his date after a
while two beautiful girls approach the
bar and Bo offers to buy them drinks
however the girls leave immediately
after getting the drinks Bo doesn't
think much of it but Dana points out
that the women took advantage of him for
his money and then left Bo shrugs it off
and says they need to keep trying he
tells Dana to live his life and stop
thinking about money all the time the
next day Bo visits Dana at his apartment
he invites Dana to join him for coffee
and then head to the beach for some
paddle boarding and relaxing on the way
Bo tells Dana to live life on the edge
and stop being so cautious about
everything soon after the two are paddle
boarding on a lake B knocks Dana off his
paddle board and gets knocked off in
return there's some underlying
aggression in Dana which impresses his
friend Bo makes it his mission to set
Dana up with a date however when Hunter
hears of this Mission he laughs at it
and calls it lame he proudly describes
his sex life to the two friends saying
he is on a mission of his own Hunter
plans to sleep with 50 women in 52 weeks
the girl he was with at the club was
woman number 46 while they are talking
the group of friends spots a beautiful
girl sunbathing nearby immediately
Hunter says he will make her his number
47th Dana scoffs at this suggestion
saying that the girl is too smart for
him because she is reading a book the
talk escalates into a bet if Hunter
doesn't manage to sleep with the girl
before both bow and Dana get a kiss on
the lips from their dates he will pay
them $200 and be their servant for 2
weeks however if he manages that Dana
would have to pay him $200 and be his
servant for 2 weeks B quickly calls his
ex-girlfriend and arranges his side of
the BET despite calling it cheating
Hunter is not worried as he knows Dana
would never be able to get a date let
alone a kiss to add to the humiliation
he immediately goes to the girl and
manages to get her phone number later
that night Dana calls Bo and tells him
he wants to win the bet against Hunter
he reveals that he made a profile on a
dating site earlier that afternoon
however despite texting 30 women he
hasn't got a reply yet concerned at this
news Bo comes to his apartment to help
him after a quick glance he asks Dana to
completely overhaul his dating profile
in order to attract women he tells Dana
to add vacation photos smile more and
say he makes over $100,000 a year as a
doctor after a bit of discussion they
agree to have a photo shoot for his
dating profile the next day the next
morning the two friends set out for
Dana's photo shoot they pick out some
shirts for Dana and head to the park
Bose suggests taking pictures with dogs
as women love dogs a kind woman helps
them take some great photos with her
puppy later at a cafe they ask a
stranger to take a picture of them
pretending to be on vacation after the
day out the two friends head back to
Bose's apartment then they update Dana's
dating profile with the new photos they
took Dana does not want to mention that
he is a doctor in his bio however Dana
is not picky about the girl's appearance
but she cares about her income Dana
believes that men and women should split
the bill on the first date bis agrees
and thinks that Dana should lower his
expectations about the girl's salary
additionally he says that men should
always pay on the first date to increase
their chances of sleeping with the girl
however due to his recent divorce
settlement Dana wants the girl to earn
just as much as him not wanting to argue
more he leaves the apartment as he
departs he sees the same girl that he
Dana and Hunter saw at the beach he
later discovers that her name is
Stephanie and he lives in the same
apartment complex as Bo Dana wants to
talk to her but cannot muster up enough
courage later at night Dana is upset
because he couldn't talk to Stephanie he
feels like he missed an opportunity to
make a good impression on her mentally
exhausted he Slumbers on the couch and
drifts into sleep a little while later
Bo calls Dana and tells him that he and
Hunter are coming over to play poker
having read a book on poker earlier that
week Dana feels Goose about his chances
of winning this time around determined
not to let Hunter beat him again he
confidently puts all his chips in
however Hunter is an experienced player
and he quickly figures out what cards
Dana has lo and behold as Dana shows his
cards it matches perfectly with Hunter's
prediction making Dana a loser once more
as a result of this loss Hunter makes B
clean his toilet and Dana iron his shirt
like a maid to add to the insult Hunter
flexes his sex life to Dana and further
taunts him by saying he will use glow in
the dark condoms to have sex with
Stephanie frustrated Dana leaves the
home cursing Hunter under his breath
after getting humiliated repeatedly Dana
finally has some good news the next day
he has received received several matches
on his new dating profile unsure of what
to do next he calls Bo for advice Bo
suggests that he ask the girls out on
dates right away although hesitant Dana
agrees and now has three dates lined up
however Dana still struggles with his
awkwardness he greets his dates with
stiff handshakes and finds it difficult
to maintain conversations unfortunately
none of his dates leads to a kiss
worried about losing the bet to Hunter
Bo decides to sit near Dana's table on
his last date and provides him with
subtle cues Dana's last date arrives
after a pleasant conversation the lady
compliments him on his travel pictures
which he had faked on B's suggestion it
turns out she is a well-traveled person
herself and asks Dana about his favorite
places to visit he makes up stories
about his travels and says Paris is his
favorite City feeling uncomfortable with
his lies Dana takes a break in the
washroom Bo follows him there and
encourages Dana to lie with confidence
he reminds Dana to confidently go for a
kiss at the end of the date Dana gathers
his courage and finishes the date as his
date is about to leave he leans in for a
kiss however his awkwardness gets the
better of him and he ends up kissing her
on the back of the head Bo arrives after
the girl leaves and scolds Dana for his
awkwardness and lack of initiative
feeling frustrated and defeated Dana
leaves alone the scene shifts to B's
apartment where he's waiting for
Hunter's arrival it's the night of
Stephanie's date and the two friends
spend their time drinking tequila and
playing Jenga Bo tries to stall for time
hoping Dana can talk to Stephanie
without Hunter noticing after after the
last tequila shot Hunter tells Bo to
prepare the money and a list of chores
for Dana his soon to be servant just
then Bo's phone rings and he glances
down from his apartment to the shock of
Hunter and B they witness Dana and
Stephanie sharing a passionate kiss by
the poolside Hunter is baffled by how
Stephanie could choose Dana over him the
scene flashes back to a few moments
earlier with time running out Dana makes
a bold move and knocks on Stephanie's
door he introduces himself as a friend
of her neighbor he then reveals the
entire story about the bet between
Hunter and him hearing about hunter's
views on women Stephanie is disgusted
and decides to help Dana determined to
teach Hunter a lesson both of them put a
show of public display of affection
right under his nose as they kiss
Stephanie expresses her appreciation to
Dana for saving her from being just
another Pawn in some silly bet in the
final scenes of the movie we witness the
consequences of Hunter losing the bet
Dana instructs Hunter to serve as their
Rick Shaw driver scha furring him and
Stephanie around the city as the new
couple enjoys their dates and kisses
Hunter is reduced to silently watching
and fetching candy for them the movie
concludes with b and Dana playfully
teasing Hunter as he struggles to pull
their rickshaw